okay we're doing death incarnate we're
back and [ __ ] is going crazy [ __ ] okay
yes
hey that a ham
yeah I'm the chef that [ __ ] serving up
some death [ __ ] suck my dick
that's my deck
Oh
[Music]
you are alive I was starting to wonder
considering most of us announced dead
and I assumed as much and before you ask
no I don't think well hell that I did my
sorry High Council to be great in doubt
so we've got that the [ __ ] out of here
checking on that way
that's like I get out of here I am your
only salvation see the back
what the [ __ ]
that's just my little night with Lena
I'm Sam I'm going as fast as I can you
stupid she-devil I don't see you helping
one more oh but my tennis there I think
so just hold on a moment up in it you
must be with actress here in the dark
brotherhood sanctuary hey what the [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa slow down it's all right
been through a lot maybe you should just
sit down for a bit she's here my sis if
I thought we'd lost her let's go wash a
bench
antes y you're alive yeah believe there
is much I have to say I'm sorry so very
sorry the pendant is oculata marrow oh
by the surface I was such a fool all of
this it's all my fault you don't you see
but but your don't you see I prayed to
the night mother I'm saying you were
right and to prove my earth you must
kill the heck I bet you have no choice
oh thank you
head by the sands I still here wrap my
head around if I have okay and my weight
bench I can't kicking your thigh what is
that
[Music]
I need to get to the night mother [ __ ]
ago I put it on here is dead it is as it
should be may she find redemption in the
void the rod but while you live the dark
brother we must fulfill our contract
emperor Titus needs must be image speak
with a maund watch here at the ballad
mare in white rather he will know the
true Emperor no cage I first if all not
be of your plan for you other and must
find this family together ok thank you